en fait tous les jours je prends tout ça
depuis plusieurs mois voilà
systématiquement depuis un an
j'alterne des phases où je vais mieux et
des phases de rechute avec des épisodes
de fièvre avec des sueurs nocturnes avec
des difficultés respiratoires
il ya des jours où simplement d'emmener
mon fils à l'école pour moi c'est hyper
fatigant aujourd'hui ce qui subsistent
principalement ce sont des séquelles
cardiaques qui sont assez importantes
puisque aujourd'hui donc je souffre
d'une péricardite aiguë chronique
quand nous n'arrivons pas à soigner je
suis allé trois fois aux urgences à la
demande de mon de mes médecins
à chaque fois je n'arrivais quasiment
plus à marcher tellement j'avais mal
tellement j'étais essoufflé à certains
moments où je suis allé aux urgences
j'avais une forte fièvre et
systématiquement on m'a renvoyé chez moi
avec du doliprane en me disant c'est
normal c'est le corona virus limites
arrêtez de vous plaindre en fait ça va
passer et d'ailleurs pas plus tard que
ce matin j'ai décidé d'aller consulter à
l'hôpital américain à paris donc je suis
allé dans un hôpital qui coûte très cher
que je dois payer moi même et pour qu'on
m'annonce que j'ai des séquelles
irrémédiables à cause des personnes qui
m'ont reçu précédemment et qui n'ont pas
pris au sérieux mais symptômes
je vais le payer en fait pour le reste
de ma vie donc là je vais mettre sur la
page donc d'après j-20 l'association
donc comme ils l'ont si moi j'ai rejoint
des groupes sur facebook de malades et
là c'est vrai que alors ça m'a fait du
bien ça m'a rassuré alors c'est pas
rassurant mais en tout cas ça m'a fait
du bien de voir que je n'étais pas seul
j'étais pas seul et surtout on était
nombreux à décrire pour certains les
mêmes symptômes alors pour d'autres
c'est d'autre chose mais en tout cas moi
j'ai trouvé des personnes qui décrivait
exactement les mêmes symptômes que moi
et aujourd'hui ces groupes font un
travail vraiment formidable ils se
battent pour la reconnaissance de duke
au vide en affection de longue durée et
ça c'est un combat très important parce
que comme on est à un an donc de deux
symptômes pour certains de maladies
qu'il ya des personnes qui sont en arrêt
maladie depuis plusieurs mois il ya des
personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
soigner et cette affection longue durée
permettrait que tous les examens
médicaux qu'on puisse faire liés à cette
affection soit pris en charge à 100%
mais permettrait aussi aux malades
aujourd'hui qui sont toujours en arrêt
maladie de bénéficier d'un arrêt maladie
avec effectivement une on va dire une
indemnité qui leur permettent de vivre
décemment
vous avez quand même des personnes qui
ont basculé dans la précarité
à cause de cette maladie il ya des
personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils n'ont pas
d'argent il se retrouve avec un
d'un demi salaire ils peuvent plus payer
leur loyer ils peuvent plus remplir leur
frigo on en est là on est en train de
créer une génération de personnes
sacrifier à cause du coronavirus et tous
ces malades de kovy blond on en fait
quoi aujourd'hui on fait quoi de ces
gens aujourd'hui on va traiter et c'est
tout à fait normal des personnes qui
sont à l'hôpital mais il faut pas
oublier des personnes qu'on a laissé
chez eux et qui aujourd'hui sont malades
depuis plusieurs mois et qui ne vont pas
mieux